hey if you'd like to support the
production of more move university video
tutorials then please visit the support
move section on move university comm
thank you and enjoy so we mentioned in
the previous video that there were short
term and long term ways to control the
the process of cholesterol synthesis and
so in this video we're going to discuss
the short term one the short term
control and that is basically going to
be the covalent modification of the
enzyme hmg-coa reductase so let's check
it out okay so here we have hmg-coa
reductase protein and has no phosphate
group we can attach that phosphate group
by investing some ATP and using a kinase
to actually add that ad or that
phosphate on and that's going to be the
amv activated protein kinase and that
would give us the hmg-coa reductase with
a phosphate group on it if we wanted to
remove that phosphate we could hydrolyze
it off and get rid of it and that would
be catalyzed by a phosphatase
specifically hmg-coa reductase
phosphatase okay so it's going to be a
phosphatase that removes the phosphate
on HMU takeaway reductase so now what's
going to go on here as far as activity
so what ends up happening here is that
the reductase without the phosphate
group is actually active so let's
actually put that in in green here so
that's active and adding that phosphate
group actually deactivates the enzyme so
it's inactive here it's inactive or at
least less active
so the reductase of course is the
committed step or the committed enzyme
the enzyme that catalyzes the committed
step in cholesterol synthesis so if it's
active what's going on with cholesterol
synthesis again misspellings huh
synthesis synthesis okay so what's going
on with cholesterol synthesis if it's
reductase is active it's going to be
active right cholesterol synthesis
synthesis will be active when the
enzyme is active and the opposite would
be true right when it's inactive
cholesterol synthesis would be inactive
okay now what about the hormones so
which hormones would activate this
kinase here there'd be hormones that
trigger the trigger via the inhibition
or the slowing down of the cholesterol
synthesis if they're going to promote
the addition of this phosphate group
they're going to make it so that
cholesterol synthesis is not active so
that's going to be the catabolic hormone
glucagon and epinephrine and they're
going to they're going to basically
stimulate the production or of this
inactive form of the enzyme right making
cholesterol synthesis inactive whereas
the anabolic hormone insulin will
trigger the phosphatase that removes
that phosphate and allows the reductase
to be active because it's anabolic right
so we've got an anabolic hormone here in
insulin right anabolic and then these
guys are catabolic right so now that
we've just
that's a sort of overview I mean it is a
little bit more complicated than what I
just mentioned but that should be enough
for the introductory level biochemist or
biochemistry student I have a question
here though what other enzyme involved
with lipid metabolism that's kind of a
hint there is deactivated by
phosphorylation and fatty acid synthesis
was a pretty huge hint right the fatty
acid synthesis enzyme is acetyl co a
carboxylase right that that enzyme
catalyzes the committed separate fatty
acid synthesis and that one is also
deactivated by phosphorylation the
reason why I wanted to ask that here is
because oftentimes adding a phosphate
group activates something so it's not
often when you you come across a
situation which adding a phosphate
deactivates an enzyme or makes it less
active so these are two cases of which
that happens or said in case so I wanted
to mention that here and sort of call
back to another area of lipid metabolism
so I hope that video was helpful thank
you for watching thanks for watching and
be sure to LIKE comment subscribe and
share the video and one new thing might
find it helpful thanks and happy
studying